- [Interviewer] So, is
it Tasha or Natasha?
- It's Tasha.
- [Interviewer] Tasha.
So Tasha, Tasha.
Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- [Tasha] I'm from Chicago,
but I grew up in Long beach, California
- [Interviewer] Long beach.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents?
- [Tasha] Yeah, I had both of my parents
up until the age of seven.
Then at seven, my mom brought
us out here from Chicago
on train one late night.
My dad came home and he
found out his family was gone
to California.
So we came out of here
and I started growing up
in Long beach.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- It was all right.
It was, it was, well,
I had a good childhood
in a bad childhood because I
chose all the wrong things.
I started using drugs
early at the age of 16.
And he went bad from there on
- [Interviewer] Any like child abuse?
- No, not really.
- [Interviewer] No.
- Not really.
- [Interviewer] No, you avoided that.
- No, I didn't get child abuse.
I was abused, sexual abused,
but I wasn't child abused.
I wasn't beaten.
- [Interviewer] When you
say sexually abused, by who?
- Yeah. I got messed and lasted
about a couple of my
uncles on my father's side.
- [Interviewer] When you were, how old?
- When I was like six,
six and seven, I remember it.
- [Interviewer] How long did that go on?
- That went on for like a year
and then we moved away.
So then after that was it.
- [Interviewer] So how'd
your life go on after?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] As a teenager?
How was your life?
I mean, what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- Real bad. I fought a lot.
I fought a lot in school.
I didn't study, like I should
because I wanted to be into gangs.
So I need more into gangs.
I sell drugs while I was in school.
I got kicked out early
for selling marijuana.
I went to Long Beach Jordan.
I got kicked out and
then I went to the Hutch.
That's the lowest you can
go out there, you go to
you get kicked out of Long Beach schools.
I went till it Hutch for a little while.
And then I ended up being
kicked out of there.
So my life was just on the run after that.
- [Interviewer] Then when
did prostitution become?
- It became at the age of,
like 18 to support my habit.
- [Interviewer] Which was crack?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And
how, how did that begin?
Did you work for the pimp or?
- No, I didn't grow up with a pimp.
I was always into doing my own thing
but I grew up around pimps and whores.
So I saw a lot and I learned a lot just
by watching them things that
other girls would go through
scared me enough to the point
where I didn't want no pimp.
You know?
So I did mostly, I did my own thing
but I had a lot of problems
with pimps because I didn't
wouldn't choose, you know, so
but I avoided that by the grace of God,
I avoided that.
But I seen a lot of bad things happen
to a lot of girls.
- [Interviewer] Did you
have some rough experiences?
- Oh Yes, I remember one
time when I was like I say
I had to be at least about,
maybe about 21 at this time.
And I went to the park and my,
I see a couple of my homeboys
in the park and my homeboy
came up to me and told me
that it was a white boy in
the park and a lot of money.
That was his friend that he was real cool.
And he wanted to kick it with somebody.
So I told him about you.
I said, okay, well, I'll go with him.
So then I ended up meeting a white boy.
I go with the white boy.
We go, we get scenic.
We give him a call, a cab.
And he lives in like the
white part of Long Beach.
So it's kinda nice to over
there and this area here.
So we go through his house where he lived
in a condo and we go up.
I remember going up the
stairs and I remember passing
by these other two condos, but
the doors were open, right?
So I can't remember like certain things.
So as I go up the stairs
we'd go to his house and everything.
So I was sitting in the living room
and he gave me a, a box
full of marijuana, right.
So he says, go ahead and roll your blunt.
You know, when I get back, you know
be ready when I come
back out the bathroom.
So I rolled this joint up.
And so when he came out the bathroom,
he had a gun pointed at me.
And he told me that
this was a dying thing.
Today was the day that we was gone die.
And I, and the only way
the only way that I would be able to live
if I can make his dick hard.
And that's the only
thing that would save me.
So to make a long story short
he came over there no to where I was at.
Made me take off all my clothes.
He took off his clothes
and he wrote a suicide
note because he said
once he killed me, he was
going to kill himself.
So I did what, everything I did
everything you asked me to
do, you know, nothing worked.
His penis still wouldn't get hard.
So I knew I was going to die after that.
So I asked him before,
you know, he's killed us.
Can I use the bathroom?
You know, whatever.
He said, well, go ahead
and go in their bathroom.
So I'm, while I'm in the bathroom
I'm looking around like
at the windows and see if
is there any kind of window
I can jump out of anything
but I didn't see no where I can get out.
So I flushed the toilet
like I used the bathroom
and he kept saying,
"Come on out of there
and come on out of there it's time."
So when I come out the bathroom
all I can remember is him reaching
and pointing his gun at me and shooting
but I guess he was high.
He was off balance.
So, cause he missed, when
the bullets went over my head
in some kind of way, I got the
script and run out the door
open up the door and run
out the door and what I
and I was running, I ran
through this lady house.
She had her door open and I never forget.
I just opened up the lady door.
She snatched the door open,
ran past the lady, ran in her bedroom
and ran under her bed
and got up under her bed.
And she lacked, I can hear
her screaming to her son
come out of the bathroom.
There's a naked lady
under the bed and her son
he came out the bathroom.
He was like, maybe his mom
was tripping or something.
Right?
And he looked under the bed
and he seen me and I was telling him
that the next door neighbor
is trying to kill me.
So they called the police
and the police told all of
us to just stay down on the,
you know, on the ground on the floor.
You know what I'm saying?
It made me stay on the floor
until the police came, right.
So he must've went outside looking
for me because when he went outside
he didn't have nothing on,
but his shirt, but his pants.
And when he went outside and looked for me
I was in the neighbor's house.
He didn't know what I was
in the neighbor's house.
So he came on downstairs.
By that time, the Long
Beach police department had
the whole place surrounded.
He pointed his gun at the police
and Long Beach police
shot this man 18 times
and he didn't die.
So make a long story short
So after they shot him,
they told me, they told me
on the phone that there's
going to be a knock
on the door and it's
going to be two officers.
And for me to go outside with the officer
I'll never forget the lady.
Cause I didn't have no clothes.
The lady gave me a pair of underwear.
I'll never forget.
The long pair of yellow socks,
I'll never forget them yellow socks
in the mo moon to put on covering my body
up because I was naked
when I came in the house
and the police came and
knocked on the door and got me.
And they took me to a Long
Beach, Memorial hospital
you know, to do the rape
thing and everything.
And I had the detectives would come
and see me and shit.
They let me go home.
They was asking me if I
asked somewhere to stay.
If I knew they needed me, you know
in case the man didn't die or something
or need me to go to court
and stuff, you know?
But by me being in the
streets and the drugs
the last thing I want to
do is having anything to do
with the police or anything like that.
You know, I was just so
glad that I didn't die
and they saved me.
So months and months went on by, right?
And I had stopped going to talk
to the detectives and everything.
And one night, I never forget,
it was raining one night.
And my stepmother, you
know, she was a drunk.
She used to be all around the neighborhood
hanging out in front of the liquor store.
So the police was riding around.
They had my picture and they
must've ran across my step-mom
and told my step mama that,
you know, they looking
for me, it's very important
that they, that they see me.
And so I was so happy to be
in the house that day, she came home
she never even told me the
police was looking for me.
Cause if he hadn't told
them, I wouldn't have left
I wouldn't have been there.
So it was raining that night and all
all the homies kicked it at her house.
So nothing was much just watching a game.
It was just. It's raining.
We all in the house watching movies
cause it's raining outside you know?
And it was the two big white boys knocking
on the door and I never forget it.
And they, and they knocked
on the door and one
of my friends, they was at
the house, answer the door.
And they said they was looking
for Latasha Grant, which is me.
And so they told me, they talked to me.
The police said, you listen, you're not
you're not under arrest.
You're not going to jail or nothing.
The detective just needs to
talk to you about, you know
the man that got shot
and raped you, you know, and everything.
And they just need you to come down.
You're going to let you go.
So I'm thinking, okay, I'll go.
So I asked him, can I put
on some clothes first?
You know, cause it's raining
and they let me pull off some clothes.
And I went with you,
I went with them to Long Beach jail.
I ended up staying at Long
Beach jail for two months
before I even talked to a
detective, they locked me
up as a civil content
until the day I could go
to court and testify against the man.
Cause he never died, he lived.
So I had to go to court to
testify in front of him,
in front of the judge,
you know what he did to me and everything.
So once I did that, once
I went to court and I
seen this man again.
And then when I seen his
man, like I got chills all
over my body because it's
thinking that this man
was gone kill me and himself,
but I made it through that.
And so I testified in
court that day and then
they let me go.
They let me go after that.
So that traumatized me for
a long time after that.
You know, after that experience
with the man that traumatized me, so.
Then I ended up going to
prison a little bit after that
you know?
And I did out, I was on parole.
I was on parole 13 years.
I couldn't get off parole for
nothing in the world whenever
I get it and go to jail,
go to jail for just
little stupid shit and I get out,
I go back, I get out.
Cause my mind was going into that.
You know what I'm saying?
And the only thing that could
clear my head is for me to
I think, you know, just get high.
It just cover all that in.
You know what I'm saying? So.
- [Interviewer] Any children?
- Anything else you got to ask me?
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- I have one son.
- [Interviewer] And you raised him?
- No, my mom raised him.
I couldn't raise him.
- [Interviewer] You're on the street.
- Yeah. By choice.
I didn't have to be, you know what I mean?
But I chose to be out there
on the street because
that's what I figured.
That's, that's why I had fun
at, you know what I'm saying?
I had fun, but all
drama, the drama was fun
I think it was more fun than high itself.
You know what I'm saying?
Being around.
- [Interviewer] I've head that a lot.
Where a lot of people say
that they are addicted to the
- The drama, it was a lot of fun.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
the drama of the street
rather than the drugs themselves.
- Yeah, that's where I had the fun at.
So that's why I stayed out
there so long in the streets.
I'm 52 years old today.
- [Interviewer] Today's your birthday?
- No, not today's my birthday,
but I'm just saying in general
- [Interviewer] Did you get, did you get
do you get depressed or
down sometimes from yeah.
- Yes. I have a PSTD right now.
I have back flashes and nightmares.
You know, sometime I'm scared.
Sometimes I think people
are really following me.
Sometime, I get scared to
get somebody don't get me
because I'm happy and I'm nervous.
You know what I mean?
Like, you know, I don't know
because the wrong I have done
because I'm not been no angel
but I guess it's knowledge catching up
to me because I ain't
got so much older now.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] What age
did you start using crack?
- I was 16.
- [Interviewer] 16. Are
you still using today?
- Yes.I like to be honest with you,
I don't wanna lie.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Now if you're
down here, that's kind of
- It's kinda hard.
- [Interviewer] It's hard not to.
- It's hard but I can say
that I'm a better person
than I am today than I was then.
Like things that I've done
then I wouldn't do today.
You know, my I'm more
responsible, you know,
I have my own place.
I pay my own bills now,
you know what I'm saying?
I take care of myself better.
You know what I mean?
I'm just, you know
- [Interviewer] How do you think
this lifestyle has changed you,
living on the streets?
- It made me appreciate and pre realized
that I'm not better than nobody.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
That now that I got my feet
that I'm doing a little better for myself
that if I see somebody
that was in my situation
that I won't judge them, I will help them.
You understand what I'm saying to them?
Well, it was a time when
I thought I was better
than them when I wasn't shit either.
And I would judge them, like
I was better than I wasn't
but today I know, you know what I mean?
If I see a girl that needs something
somebody might need a
dollar or two and I got it.
You know what I'm saying?
I would give it, you feel me.
Today I would go shopping for myself,
pay my bills first,
take care of my hiking's
and stuff as a woman's supposed to do.
And then I'll do whatever's left.
You know what I'm saying?
But yeah, it's changed me a lot.
It made me a better person, actually.
I think, I think it made my heart
a lot better cause I was bitter.
- [Interviewer] That's interesting.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What advice would you give
to a young woman who's
kind of enticed by the,
the street life?
- To stop because you
know, you may not make it.
You may not make it to be by age,
you know what I'm saying?
Stop right now and listen
to what people are telling you
and go to know to go the other way.
Because see, I was just
fortunate that I'm still hear
that I still got my mind did I
ain't went all the way crazy.
But I didn't know shit
didn't make me just as crazy
as that woman sitting over
there and talking to herself
and can't even realize that
she did wetted on herself.
I could be in that same situation.
You may not make it.
So the best thing to do is listen to
you know what I'm saying to change
on life right now,
because life is precious.
And before, you know,
the years is gone just like that.
And you'd be wake up one day
you're 60 years old and you'd be like,
"Damn, what happened?"
And that's cause you didn't listen.
And I didn't either it,
but I learned the hard way.
These, these last years I
got, I was trying to live
into the best of my ability,
you know, with no regrets.
- [Interviewer] You have no regrets from?
- I have none.
- [Interviewer] Do you think that
if your childhood had been different
that maybe your life
would be different today?
- No. I'm not going to say that
because a lot of people
have good childhoods
and they still in this position here.
- [Interviewer] It's true.
- You know, because I chose
all the bad decisions.
'Cause I knew right from wrong
and I wanted to go wrong.
He telling me, don't go.
You telling me to go right?
And don't go left.
I'm going left
because something must
be very interesting left.
So I want to go see
what's popping over there.
You know, like you said,
don't go to that house.
That's the bad house right there.
Soon as I get a chance I'm going right
down to that house because
it's cracking, you know?
So that's all that was
my, I made bad decisions.
- [Interviewer] Are you
living on the street?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Where you at?
- I stay across the street, at the Fort.
- [Interviewer] Oh,
you're at the Fort hotel
- It's apartments
- [Interviewer] Yeah. It's nice.
- The apartments given us
a to show people that rent
out in the street has been
irresponsible to show them
start how to start it back living again.
And a lot of people from there,
they moved to apartments.
You know, one bedrooms, two bedrooms.
You gotta crawl before you walk.
- [Interviewer] Where you living
on the street at one point?
- Yes.
(interviewer laughs)
Of course
- [Interviewer] And the Fort
is kind of a step between them.
- Yeah, but I was living,
but see the only different is.
And I try to be better than nobody.
I was not living in on the street in LA.
I was living in the street in Long Beach.
You know what I'm saying?
When I mean living in the street,
living from house to house.
I literally, literally I never really
never really literally
lived out in the street.
You know what I'm saying?
Like outside, I've always had a house
people houses and I could go to
- [Interviewer] You just
crush wherever you can.
- Yeah, yeah.
You know, sometimes you
got to pay to, you know
pay to stay, whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
But, I've never had to
be literally outside.
- [Interviewer] What are
you doing for money now?
- I'm on SSI right now.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- So I'm okay.
- [Interviewer] Takes the
pressure of you to do the
- Yeah, I don't have to
do all that stuff anymore.
Pays my bills and everything.
You know, I'm doing I'm,
I'm a lot better now.
I'm like, I put it like this here.
My story is really to let
people know that you can change.
You can get better.
You know, you can, if
you want to, you know.
- [Interviewer] Tasha, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- You welcome.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- Thank you.
It was nice to meet you too.
- [Interviewer] You too girl
- [Tasha] I finally got to here
to do an interview with you.
(interviewer laughs)
I been trying to get
here with you forever.
- [Interviewer] Forever?
- [Tasha] Yeah, I have.